our series vaccinating america focuses
on what you need to know as the fda
advisory committee considers the pfizer
biontech
vaccine canada approved the vaccine
yesterday but there are some potential
side effects that people should be aware
of we're going to get to that first i
want to let you know that two of the
first people
to receive the pfizer vaccine in the uk
experienced adverse events after the
injection
now you also need to know that both
patients had a history of allergic
reactions and both of them have
recovered
our dr john lapook joins us now with how
this could affect the vaccine rollout dr
lapook good morning to you
let's start there in the uk we hear that
there were two significant
adverse events in the in the initial
rollout what does that tell us
here in the u.s about what to expect
good morning tony well you know we don't
have really a ton
of information about it we know there
were two health care workers uh who had
such severe history of allergies that
they carried epipens with them
and shortly after getting the vaccine uh
they developed a severe reaction and
they
fortunately were able to give themselves
the epipen and got better you know
that type of reaction tends to be very
rare of course our regulator is going to
be
wanting to look at it very closely i
spoke to tony fauci about it last night
he said
you can bet that today that's going to
be in the discussions in the eua
application that the fda is going to be
having but the more common
reactions are much much milder and what
are those common reactions what should
people
be prepared for as we start getting
injections as soon as saturday
well there are reactions that show that
the vaccine is actually working that
it's stimulating your immune system
so uh redness at the injection site site
pain swelling you may have some fever or
a headache some muscle aches
fatigue things like that they tend to be
transient they go away
in a couple of days and then off you go
it's actually a sign that says okay
my immune system saw something it
reacted to it and uh
hopefully it's the beginning of me being
protected yeah as we talk about
side effects i don't want people to lose
sight of the main effect which is
an increasingly well-described
protection against the coronavirus
itself
on that subject i know you've dug into
the data that fires are provided to the
fda
what stood out to you
you know what what stood out to me was
how much information there was and
the detail that was there uh 53 pages
from the fda alone and then much more
than that from pfizer i looked at every
word of it
and i got to tell you tony i would be
flabbergasted
if this emergency use authorization is
not approved
today i really would i think that with
about a 95
efficacy rate at a time when there's a
raging pandemic
and we heard about the statistics about
what's going on across the country if
you look at a map it's like it's on fire
and so far the safety profile looks good
i mean
less than one percent uh like point six
three percent of
of uh reaction side effects uh in the uh
in the plus uh in the vaccine group
versus
0.51 in the in the placebo group so a
little bit more
and they're going to be looking over the
over the years and over the months to
see
what happens not when 44 000 people take
the pfizer vaccine but when millions of
people
uh take it so let's talk about those
millions of people what is the magic
number
that we're paying attention to how many
people need to get vaccinated before we
can feel like okay we're going to get
past this
so we're hearing about this herd
immunity number that fluctuates
depending upon how you look at it
so it could be anywhere from say 70 to
80 85 percent of people needing to be
protected now how do you get there so
for one thing
you have natural immunity unfortunately
that's happening so we're having some
herd immunity happening because it's
such a huge outbreak in the country
right now
on top of that you have the vaccine 95
percent effective
and we're hearing from months of
slaughter yesterday he told me that by
mid end of march we should have 100
million people vaccinated
and then but that's not going to get you
to the 70 75 80 percent number
especially if it turns out that 40
percent of america
is not going to be taking the vaccine
because they're afraid right now so we
have a lot of education to do
and the bottom line here is we still
need to be wearing
the masks the washing our hands doing
everything we've been told
because at the beginning until we know
what's going on you can assume that if
you've got the vaccine that you're
protective
we have to have belt and suspenders well
that that education campaign
telling people what to expect uh i think
that begins today with you dr john
lapook thank you very much we appreciate
it we'll course continue our coverage